[MUSIC]
One of the research projects at the
Stanford Rock Center, is taking a look
at the role of social media in, for senior
executives, and board members.
What we've done is a survey of a couple
hundred senior executives and board
members, asking them questions about, how
well do you understand social media?
Do you, do you use it personally?
And also, you know, what are you actually
doing in the company?
Are you collecting this information?
Where does it go?
Are you using it?
Do you find it valuable, and things like
that.
One of the key findings is that most of
the companies are using social media,
but it really doesn't get up to the senior
level or Board level.
It's basically used for
customer, outreach, a bit of marketing,
things like that.
At the Board level, you know, you know,
very, very little.
I mean, the, sort of the verbatim
responses that we got were, this is new.
We're not sure what it is.
Seems interesting.
It's like, you know, is this just another
flash in the pan.
I think the social media thing scares
companies as well.
They've seen certain things go viral,
typically viral in a bad way.
What happened, you know, why couldn't we
have controlled that, that kinda thing.
It's a new, technology that they're
actually not that familiar with,
it's hard for them to think through the
ramifications of it.
I think it's also hard for them to say,
okay, if we do this,
you know, is there a business case to be
made?
Are we sure that this is value accretive
or not.
From our side, we think it is a valuable,
place for information.
There's a lot of topics in social media
that are,
that map directly into high level
management and, and, board structure.
I think one of the key ones, is all the
elements of risk management.
You hear things that are, that are coming
months, or maybe years ahead of time.
That would help you manage a reputation of
the organization, and at the board level,
you know, worry about risks that sometimes
you get blindsided by.
I think it is inevitable that it's gotta
have an impact on, on, companies.
You know, how they attach to their
employees, how they attach to suppliers.
There's [INAUDIBLE] attached to customers.
We're still trying to figure out, you
know, what are, what are the steps.
Lots of the companies that do this are
collecting and analyzing and
tracking data, and providing, you know,
strategies around, around social media.
What happens when that information is
inside the organization?
What does it do?
What it, what processes are changed?
You know, can you show that value's being
created?
That's really why we did the survey.
What are people doing, people are making
decisions,
how informed are they, and things like
that.
[BLANK_AUDIO]